alright one last item and we've been
following this case at pro football
TOCOM there haven't been many
developments lately but this week in the
Robert Kraft solicitation of
prostitution criminal prosecution there
was an offer made to dismiss the case in
exchange for an acknowledgement that if
there had been a trial that he would
have been found guilty that's a
non-starter as reported by TJ Quinn of
ESPN other reports Kraft has said no and
here's why you can't make that admission
and expect to avoid any type of scrutiny
or punishment under the personal conduct
policy if you emerge with a complete and
total exoneration then what can the
Commissioner do to you but if you end up
acknowledging that you would have been
found guilty and whatever the
documentation is however it's all
written up that ends up being a problem
for you when the Commissioner does what
we assume he will do which is hold an
owner to a much higher standard than a
player now I still don't know what a
player would get yeah for this kind of
of infraction right but whatever it is
the owner gets more if you get a full
exoneration you're less likely to get
punished if you do get punished it won't
be as severe as if you admit yeah I did
it
you're just dismissing the case right
okay so I guess the thing I want to ask
you here but this is just oh all right
so we've seen players in the past though
be found not guilty or there's no
charges Pratt or you know no we're not
gonna press charges in the case or you
know we're the the the the witness is
unreliable and we can't move further
with this case and the NFL still
suspends the player so do you think
those guidelines fall true here with
like a Robert Kraft like the fact of
like the protection of the shield well
here's the difference the cases where
we've seen a player end up being
suspended without any type of criminal
prosecution all involve some form of
violence or sexual assault Ben
Roethlisberger allegations of sexual
assault never arrested never charged
right but he was suspended because there
is that violence that sexual assault
component to it right well Ray Rice is a
different one Ezequiel it's the one I
was thinking of no arrests right
suspended domestic violence so that's
where I think it's different and that's
why I keep coming back to if this was a
player and and I mean let's just call it
what it is for the infractions that we
see that are attributed to players
they're all worse than this and if a
player did
this I don't think the punishment would
be anything close to what we see when
there is some act of violence for which
a player is suspended or otherwise
discipline so for something like this if
at the end of the day it is solicitation
of prostitution and you know it's a
probation and a fine and there's no
under the human trafficking thing
doesn't come into play with Robert Kraft
it was a pair of Florida residents then
your acted with I just don't think the
punishment would be very significant for
a player based upon the fact that the
punishments we typically see involve
crimes where there really is a victim
who was on the wrong end of some sort of
a violent confrontation yeah I mean
that's interests I don't know but I feel
like they're always hard on the players
so I don't know if I buy that all when
has there been a pleasure yeah I don't
know was Eugene Robinson the night
before superb exactly for solicitation
of prostitution right that was right
existence yeah so I know we've really
never had this instance so I don't know
what to say it about either but I guess
the other thing I want to ask you cuz I
know you know better than me like how do
you even put in the plea of not guilty
right now when they say there's video
evidence like I that just to me just
you're always not guilty there's rarely
if ever does a criminal defendant when
he or she is writing a reg I get up and
say guilty you've because you force this
state to prove it beyond a reasonable
doubt and one of the developments
yesterday and this came from the New
York Times a motion to suppress all
evidence in the case now one thought is
that's in order to keep this stuff
secret so it doesn't come out in public
because there's a videotape of what went
on in the room but I also think there's
going to be a challenge made to the
legality of the taping process which
goes to the legality of the evidence and
if the evidence ends up not being as
visible right prove the case
yeah if there's no video you can't prove
the case and even with the video you got
to prove that there was solicitation I
don't know how they're gonna prove there
was solicitation if all they have is
video of a sexual act that doesn't prove
that it was illegally solicited with a
promise to pay money on the other side
of it and even if money changed hands on
the other side of it that doesn't mean
there was a promise it could have just
been a gift you know and it sounds but
it's serious that's really you have to
be able to prove every element of the
case yeah and one of the key elements of
the case
is that there was some sort of
solicitation yeah that's the name of the
crime so there's flaws here and if
Crafton wants to fight this there's a
good chance he's gonna win it and he's
gonna get that exoneration and there's
some other rich powerful people involved
us in them too where I just feel like
this is gonna be an uphill fight for the
the for the district attorney hey look I
mean somebody decided to to take on a
fight that is going to be a difficult
one for the prosecution to win that and
why else would they offer this deal
where we'll just let it all go away like
it never happened as long as you admit
we would have won yeah what is that well
it sounds like they were wrong with the
human trafficking aspect of this whole
thing
I mean they were wrong there was none of
the alleged victims of human trafficking
were involved with Robert Kraft yet to
see anything to suggest that they did
bust up a human traffic yes right that's
what I was referring to all right that's
it for today's PFT ot but later today
Chris Sims unbuttoned in the pft p.m.
co-branded podcast he's got a much you
know I've been doing PFT live for eight
bleeping years and I don't have a mug
hey Casey
I want my mug they like me better by and
that's not shocking
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports